ya hemos visto la reacción general para
una hidra vor acción oxidación y en el
vídeo anterior hicimos este ejercicio
como uno de nuestros problemas de
práctica comenzamos con este al que no y
obtuvimos este alcohol con él lo ha
añadido en el carbono menos sustituido
echemos un vistazo al mecanismo para
esta reacción en el paso número 1
añadimos nuestro verano vih 3 y si
observas la estructura de puntos de aquí
abajo
el boro tiene hibridación sp2 lo que
significa que tiene geometría tribunal-
plana y también un orbital p vacío el
cual puede aceptar un par de electrones
porque como puedes ver el boro tiene
sólo 6 electrones a su alrededor y el
hecho de que no tenga un octeto lo
vuelve muy reactivo de hecho el bora no
puede reaccionar con sí mismo y es por
eso que tenemos th efe
aquí para estabilizarlo entonces cuando
el verano se aproxima a nuestro al que
no aquí está nuestro al que no tenemos
los dos grupos
y lo justo aquí y también tenemos los
dos hidrógenos en este carbono aquí
están los dos hidrógenos muy bien
entonces el bora no se acerca al carbono
en el lado izquierdo del doble enlace y
una razón por la que el bora no se
acerca al carbono del lado izquierdo es
que estos grupos metilo son
relativamente voluminosos generan
impedimento estético que previene al
boro de acercarse al carbono del lado
derecho del doble enlace y los
electrones iban a atacar al boro los
electrones iban a atacar al orbital
vacío del boro y van a formar un enlace
entre el carbono del lado izquierdo del
enlace y el boro por lo que estos
electrones peas se van a mover hacia acá
y mientras ese enlace entre este carbono
y este boro se está formando estamos
retirando densidad electrónica del
carbono en la derecha entonces solo voy
a colocar una carga parcial positiva
aquí
porque este es un mecanismo concertado
este paso en el mecanismo es concertado
y mientras se forma este enlace estamos
incrementando la carga parcial positiva
en este carbono y eso desencadena un
desplazamiento de hidruro recordemos que
un libro es un hidrógeno con dos
electrones
por lo que tiene una carga formal
negativa así que podemos pensar que hay
un hidruro justo aquí voy a marcar estos
electrones en azul entonces estos
electrones de aquí abajo en azul se
sienten atraídos a la carga parcial
positiva que se está formando por lo que
vamos a formar un enlace justo aquí
entre este carbono y el hidrógeno y los
electrones en azul se mueven para acá
entonces la formación de esta carga
parcial positiva desencadena el
desplazamiento de hidruro y movemos esos
electrones en azul hacia allá para
formar un enlace ahora vamos a dibujar
el producto de la
izquierdo de donde el doble enlace
estaba vamos a tener b h 2 y del lado
derecho vamos a tener h vamos a tener un
grupo metilo saliendo hacia nosotros en
el espacio y un grupo metilo alejándose
de nosotros en el espacio del lado
izquierdo vamos a tener un hidrógeno
saliendo hacia nosotros y un hidrógeno
alejándose de nosotros sigamos a los
electrones los electrones en magenta de
aquí están formando este enlace entre el
carbono y el boro y la formación del
enlace y carbono boro desencadena el
desplazamiento de hidruro por lo que los
electrones en azul se mueven hacia acá y
esto es lo que obtenemos más adelante en
este mecanismo observaremos que el h va
a estar en donde se encuentra el boro él
lo h va a estar aquí y entonces podemos
hablar de región química y de estéreo
química para esta reacción pensemos en
la región química en porque lo h se
añade al carbono
- sustituido esto ocurre por dos razones
una razón sería el impedimento estético
es decir estos grupos metilo previenen
alborán o de acercarse al carbono que
está en el lado derecho del doble enlace
entonces el impedimento estético es una
razón y también la formación de la carga
parcial positiva en desarrollo en este
carbono está mejor estabilizada debido a
la presencia de estos grupos metilo bien
entonces tenemos dos razones impedimento
estético y el factor estabilizante de
estos grupos metilo que estabilizan a la
carga parcial positiva que se está
desarrollando y esto explica por qué el
boro se añade al carbono del lado
izquierdo del doble enlace y después
eventualmente es ahí donde el bache va a
ir entonces esto explica la región
química en cuanto al estéreo química
observamos que el h y el h se añaden en
el mismo lado debido a que este es un
mecanismo concertado esto prácticamente
ocurre al mismo tiempo por lo que la
estéreo química no
en este punto del mecanismo continuamos
con el mecanismo voy a volver a dibujar
esta molécula de aquí se ve un poco
complicada déjenme hacerla un poco más
sencilla de ver tenemos nuestros grupos
metilo y luego tenemos nuestro bh 2
justo aquí este proceso ocurre dos veces
más porque hay otros dos hidrógenos en
el boro por lo que terminamos formando
un trial killed ahora no voy a dibujar
el boro con tres grupos alquilo unidos a
él el tri al kiel bola no se debería de
ver así algunos libros de texto lo
dibujan como un mono al kiel verano y
prosiguen con la parte de oxidación de
esta reacción pero la mayoría de las
veces tenemos un trial kill verano y eso
es lo que veremos aquí continuamos al
paso de oxidación recuerden es el
segundo paso de aquí tenemos peróxido de
hidrógeno y tenemos iones hidróxido
vamos a dibujarlos aquí tenemos algunos
peróxido de hidrógeno dibujaré la
estructura de puntos para el peróxido de
hidrógeno con sus pares de electro
es libres en los oxígenos y tenemos
hidróxido o h menos el hidróxido va a
funcionar como una base va a tomar un
protón del peróxido de hidrógeno y dejar
estos electrones atrás en el oxígeno y
formaremos un guión hidroperóxido lo
estoy dibujando de este lado tres pares
de electrones libres en el oxígeno de la
derecha por lo que tiene una carga
formal negativa dibujaremos estos
electrones en magenta pasando al oxígeno
entonces tenemos el guión hidroperóxido
que va a funcionar como un núcleo filo y
nuestro núcleo filo va a atacar al
orbital vacío en el boro el núcleo filo
ataca al tri a silva ahora no veamos el
resultado de ese ataque ahora hay un
enlace entre el boro y el oxígeno
después hay un enlace oxígeno oxígeno y
luego hay un hidrógeno aquí y dibujaré
los pares de electrones libres en los
oxígenos los pares de electrones de aquí
el boro sigue teniendo sus tres grupos
al kilo estoy dibujando los grupos al
kilos aquí
y tenemos una carga formal negativa en
el boro el siguiente paso en el
mecanismo es la migración de un grupo
alquilo esta parte es un poco extraña
estos electrones de aquí van a formar un
enlace con el oxígeno y al mismo tiempo
estos electrones van a pasarse a este
oxígeno y formamos un hidróxido voy a
dibujarlo probablemente sea más fácil
entender de esta manera lo que está
ocurriendo aquí tenemos tres pares de
electrones libres en el oxígeno una
carga formal negativa dibujaré esto
selecciones en verde estos electrones en
verde se pasan a este oxígeno
el enlace oxígeno oxígeno es débil por
lo que es relativamente sencillo romper
este enlace ahora voy a resaltar estos
electrones de aquí estos electrones en
magenta formaron este enlace entre el
oxígeno y el boro y ahora tenemos
nuestra migración del grupo al kilo
mostraré estos electrones en azul los
electrones en azul están formando un
enlace entre este
y este oxígeno lo dibujaré es un poco
complicado de ver así que primero
dibujaré lo que tenemos y después vamos
a resaltar algunos electrones bien ahora
tenemos a nuestro oxígeno unido a este
grupo y nuestro boro ahora tiene dos
grupos alquilo unidos a él así sigamos a
los electrones los electrones en magenta
representan el enlace entre el oxígeno y
el boro y los electrones en azul serían
estos electrones de aquí entonces este
carbono está ahora unido a este oxígeno
la migración del grupo 'el kilo' remueve
la carga formal en el boro rompe el
enlace débil oxígeno de oxígeno y separa
al hidróxido este proceso ocurre dos
veces más porque tenemos estos otros dos
grupos al kilo y cuando eso sucede dos
veces más obtenemos un trial cox y ahora
no voy a dibujarlo tenemos un oxígeno
aquí y después tenemos a este grupo
saliendo de aquí
y luego de este lado tenemos nuestro
oxígeno y luego tenemos nuestro grupo
saliendo de ahí y ocurre lo mismo de
este lado muy bien en nuestro siguiente
paso el ión hidróxido funciona como un
núcleo filo el hidróxido ataca al boro
nuevamente el boro tiene un orbital
vacío entonces dibujemos el resultado
del ataque núcleo físico ahora tenemos
un nuevo h unido al boro y el boro sigue
teniendo todos estos grupos alrededor
voy a dibujar todo eso aquí puedes ver
por qué este mecanismo se está volviendo
algo enredado en este punto dibujar
todos estos grupos es algo incómodo y
tenemos una carga formal negativa en el
boro y seguimos teniendo algunos pares
de electrones libres en este oxígeno y
los estoy dibujando porque en el
siguiente paso para deshacernos de la
carga formal negativa estos electrones
se van a pasar al oxígeno y eso dará
paso a una unión al tóxico ahora tenemos
este oxígeno que tiene tres pares de
electrones libres tiene
una carga formal negativa y vamos a
resaltar los electrones estos electrones
de aquí en magenta se pasan al oxígeno y
forman nuestro anión alcock sido ya casi
acabamos muy bien en el último paso
tenemos agua presente y el agua dona un
protón a nuestro año nalca óxido
entonces el animal cosido toma el protón
del agua protón amos el animal que óxido
y formamos nuestro alcohol y terminamos
es un mecanismo muy largo pero formamos
el alcohol que vimos al inicio y sabemos
eso porque habíamos visto que él
se añade a este carbono entonces puedes
hacer este mecanismo dibujando solo el
mono al kiel verano y seguramente
algunos profesores se dejarán hacerlo de
este modo por lo general la reacción
ocurre con el tri al kiel verano y por
eso dibujé todo esto se volvió un poco
tedioso pero finalmente este es el
mecanismo para la hidro oración
oxidación